- All right, everybody,
let's close out the show
with something cool I
found on social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
My kids are really into Legos.
I am as well.
I kind of in fact pretend that it's them.
And it's me too, 'cause I
love putting them together.
It's very therapeutic.
In fact, many people of all
ages are really into Legos.
But I've never seen anything
quite as elaborate as this.
This is a love y'all.
An Austin woman and her husband
have created a huge Lego
city in their house.
It's got pretty much everything
you can imagine and more.
A thriving downtown, a fire station,
a residential neighborhood,
even a dog park.
And as her TikTok followers know,
she never misses a single detail.
- [Emily] If you looked at a
downtown area of the Lego city,
this is where all my buildings are.
All my cars, Mystery Machine.
Up here, this is like
our shopping district.
And we have a dog walker
actually with a few dogs.
And what is that there?
Dog poop.
Gross.
- We have her on the line
right now to tell us more.
Everybody say hello to
Emily watching on KEYE TV.
What's up, Emily?
- Hello everyone.
Wow, this is amazing.
- I'm gonna be honest with you,
I have tried to create
something cool like this
with my son in my house,
but nothing came close
to what you are doing.
It's incredible.
So you have followers who
try to stump you, right?
With details on your Lego City.
- Yeah, so a couple
weeks before that video
you all just watched,
some of my followers
were sending me questions
about my city like if I had random pieces.
Do I have a pig?
Do I have dog poop?
And so, I started
answering their questions
and pointing out what I have.
And really I do have
pretty much everything.
My favorite part about the city though
has gotta be the natural area
with the working waterfall.
Me and my husband designed it on our own.
So there were no instructions.
It wasn't from an official set.
- Oh, I love that.
Man, Lego should call you for ideas.
This is, that waterfall is rad.
I saw it online how it
works and you twist.
It's very cool.
How did you get into this?
- Yeah, so I feel like I'm one
of the few people out there
that never had Lego growing up.
But when I met my husband,
he was really into Lego Star Wars sets.
So we built a few of them together
and then he got me my own set,
it's called the Women of NASA.
And it came with all these different
female mini figure scientists.
I was actually getting my master's
in data science at that point,
so it really resonated with me.
And then after that I was really hooked.
I love Lego Scooby-Doo.
Like you can see a Mystery
Machine behind me here.
- Yes.
- And you know, I started
posting Lego content
right after I lost my job during COVID,
which kind of bummed me out.
But I'm grateful for where it's come.
And now I'm a Lego ambassador
and the Lego Ambassador
program's always really
looking for people to represent
different communities.
And I'm just so proud that I'm able
to represent women who are
really just new fans of Lego.
It's so exciting.
- I am one of these women.
I literally will sit with my son.
He will walk away and come back
and walk away and come back
and Mama's still there
putting it together.
It's so, the task, like,
especially if you have
a chaotic life going on,
it's a nice thing that's just
an easy instruction to follow.
You're just, it's a
nice therapeutic thing.
I'm just saying for any mamas out there
looking for something to
do with a glass of wine.
Thank you so much, Emily.
I love your city.
It's awesome.
- Thank you.
- I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheering)
And that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Oh my God.
Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- [Emily] I can't believe that.
- Thank you so much, Emily.
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Kate Mara, Dr. Jane Goodall,
Ava Louise Murchison
and Sydney.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.